we have an absolutely huge bit of news
and a major step forward
in the criminal investigation of donald
trump his associates and his
organization
uh and i am going to go back to what is
sometimes called the boiling
frog situation because it really applies
here in terms of the normalization of
what's going on
yesterday we learned that the manhattan
district attorney cyrus vance jr
has convened a grand jury to decide
whether to indict former president
donald trump
or his associates or other elements
of the trump organization this means
that the district attorney
at least believes that he has evidence
of possible crimes otherwise you don't
convene a grand jury
whether the crime was committed by trump
himself
or someone close to trump or all of the
above we don't yet know and that is
exactly what the grand jury
will determine the washington post
reports that the panel was convened
recently
and will sit three days a week for six
months
this is not super surprising in terms of
the duration
white collar crimes take a lot of grand
jury time
the cases are complicated and
typically grand juries look at more than
one matter so it probably isn't
all trump all the time for the period
that they will be on the grand jury
now as you might remember manhattan
district attorney cyrus vance has been
investigating donald trump's
pre-presidency business dealings for
more than two years now and part of that
was slowed down
because while donald trump was president
he was able to regularly obstruct
vance obtaining his tax records that
stopped when trump left office
and those records uh were directed to be
provided to cyrus vance
uh relatively recently and this is an
important detail
this investigation relates to things
trump and his company
did before trump was president and not
during
now vance's office said in court filings
that it was investigating quote possibly
extensive and protracted criminal
conduct
at the trump organization this includes
tax fraud insurance fraud
falsification of business records and a
whole bunch of other stuff now before
looking at the details
a grand jury looking at a former
president is a huge deal it's enormous
uh and we have to understand that we're
gonna
look at some things that former
prosecutor renato marriotti said and
we're going to talk about you know is
trump likely to ever go to prison the
answer is no
but consider the sort of you know the
you
the boiling frog in the skillet you
slowly turn up the temperature
it doesn't notice that it's getting
burned consider how far we've come
where as asha rangapa said on twitter
before the presidency the access
hollywood grab him by the you know what
tape oh my goodness this is crazy this
is the craziest thing we've ever seen
we have a grand jury now considering
indictments of a former president
and it didn't even make that big of news
like it made news but it wasn't
that big so think about the degree to
which things have
slid over the last many years now former
federal prosecutor renato marriotti who
has been a guest on the show
had a good twitter thread about the
meaning of all of this and just a few
points
that renato makes one quote the mere
fact that a special grand jury was
impaneled
does not mean that any particular person
will be charged it does not necessarily
mean that trump himself will be charged
but it is fair to say
that vance's investigation is far along
and that
charges are on the horizon does not mean
it will be against trump
number two when it comes to trump
himself in cases like this
it's often about what you can prove
trump knew
when you're talking about this type of
fraud in white collar crime and renato
tweets quote
whenever i investigated tax or fraud
cases the case came down to whether we
had sufficient proof of the defendant's
knowledge of the false statements
contained in the documents
that state of mind is what distinguishes
fraud from a mere mistake a slip up is
not fraud
very similar to perjury people say
things that are not true while under
oath in court
all the time but why don't we often see
perjury charges because you have to
prove they didn't just make a mistake it
wasn't just a misrecollection that they
were really lying
and state of mind is a big part of that
uh and lastly
um renato tweets quote fraud is just
when you lie to people to get their
money
so the case usually comes down to
whether the defendant
knew the statements in the documents
were false it's
easier to prove knowledge for people
involved in preparing or authorizing the
documents like weisselberg weisselberg
was one of the top
uh trump organization people and then in
terms of expectations and this matches
what i've been saying for some time
renato tweets quote don't be surprised
if people like weisselberg are their
initial target
to induce him or others to flip someone
like trump or his children will only
have liability
if they knew of the false statements and
participated in the scheme
in some way or moved it forward somehow
so this doesn't change any of the things
we've said
trump maybe would be charged no way that
this leads to trump going to prison
but but but if trump were a normal
person
i would probably be saying this guy's
going to prison they've got this guy
and what i mean by that is think back to
the michael cohen
indictment and and conviction michael
cohen
names trump in the case in which
michael cohen went to prison for his
crimes that's trump's personal lawyer
that would normally be a major sign that
trump is guilty of something
but this is a rich former president and
we have a two-tiered justice system in
the united states and these
at their core are crimes for which you
really need to prove state of mind so
this may go on for a long time
it will certainly trigger trump i don't
think trump ends up in prison but let's
talk about the reaction
from the former president next one of
our sponsors
is hydrant which is a delicious fruit
drink powder that you
mix into water for rehydration and
they're giving you 25
off your first order it's made with four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity
packed with vitamins a b c and d
which is also very much worth trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video